(audience applauds)
(tense music)
- I feel American
until I'm around something very American,
and then I'm like, "I don't like this."
(audience laughs)
Something about the American
flag is just too American.
I feel the same way
about the American flag
that I imagine white people
feel about Black people.
I don't want to be around a lot of them.
(audience laughs)
Three or four is fine.
That's plenty.
But I don't, you know, I
don't want to be surrounded.
Even "The National Anthem,"
"The National Anthem,"
when I hear "The National Anthem,"
you know what it feels like?
It feels like I'm
listening to R. Kelly now.
(audience laughs)
It's still good.
It's just hard to not think
about that other thing.
(audience applauds)
(logo whooshes)